hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a brand new amnesia
custom story study of insanity by Baja I
bought your head hurts like hell
where is everyone I'm actually really
excited to be able to do these Let's
Plays of and these custom stories
outside of last rooms because there's
there it's more immersive for me to be
playing when nobody's watching and it I
do I love amnesia I love the gameplay
and I love being scared by it and this
one is another very highly reviewed it
needs a custom story I think it's got
9.1 which is pretty much higher than you
know most of the other Wow most of the
ones I usually but I love I love amnesia
and a music got some stories I love
seeing what people can create okay I got
a journal entry and I can't move out
here we go ah that looks positively
diabolical I so I got a journal entry
find that lantern alright well if you
insist giving I thought a tenner box
that's kind of close another one I'm I'm
gonna roll got a hammer here nope locked
open a hole ooh hello door swinging open
in the wind a note a after an initial
inspection of the house we're finally
settling in and I actually have time to
start recording our findings
Melissa confirmed that the construction
of the house seems to match common 18th
century European designs beyond its size
and remote location what's drawn our
team to this house is its condition it
doesn't look like this place has been
touched in hundreds of years Alton has
been throwing out figures all day
inspecting anything his nose says might
be valuable I'm still mystified why he
went into anthropology like myself
instead of antique dealing still e's
kept our department well financed so I
can't complain too much
hearing Alton's remarks on how valuable
some of these materials are it leaves me
further surprised in how this house has
remained untouched over the years has
anything to do with the demon
infestation I'm sure some of those
furniture and decorations would fetch
some high prices
how could we be so fortunate thieves
haven't ransacked to this place yet
Frank keeps saying it's probably haunted
which I hope is just a juvenile means
Jesus I wouldn't tolerate his jokes
except he was kind enough to drive us to
the location and he was the person who
first discovered the house I'm glad he
alerted our University rather than some
cutthroat treasure hunters I think this
place has some real value in the
Historical Society and you're all dead
now you're damned curiosity has gotten
you killed lots of tinderboxes oh hello
everything seems to have a very blue oh
the lock is completely broken a special
tool may be required to break the door
you mean like a crowbar thought I saw
something you mean like a crowbar
nothing behind the painting there okay I
still don't have any lantern I need to
find one I'm compelled to some really
quiet in here
[Music]
okay this looks like the money door's
locked
come on maybe there's a huge shelter do
you see as a historian is liking to do I
found Melissa going through the books in
the East Library she tells me there are
several dozen copies of the Bible in
there and they are all in immaculate
condition as if they had rarely been
opened this struck us as strange since
there wasn't much else to do but read
back in that day and age not to mention
the cultural present and pressure to
have it practical and practically
memorized
then again religion has changed hands in
this series and so many times these were
probably covered for when the
Catholicism has turned had its turn of
dominance the only other books Melissa
has found seem to be books on Anatomy
and if you own one keeping alrighty then
is there a key in here
I would assume probably
seems like something that would be
hidden in this place or not or I could
be completely wrong hello anybody home
no right hello who dead rabbit yes Bert
look did I do that
whoops I guess this is why they gave us
so many Oh what oh hello ma'am take that
I found a secret entrance
I wonder how long it's been since the
study was used for its intended purpose
like most of the rooms in this house is
very spacious I have the impression this
house was intended for a large number of
guests and occupants melissa has been
suggesting there might be some secret
rooms or passages most likely preesh
rooms are similar Alton and Frank have
been looking over all the switches or
moveable walls I'm not convinced but I
won't dismiss the idea entirely in fact
I keep feeling a draft sitting at this
desk
I've checked the window but it's shut
shut tight where else could a breeze be
coming from um how about this
I found it before you even wrote that or
public maybe but it may be difficult to
explore the rest of the house without a
lantern well I'm not gonna stop trying
just because you're too big of a pansy
let's see lots of notes why couldn't the
former owners be kind enough to leave
all the doors unlocked so far we've
found the coat closet by the entrances
lock the back doors long Victoria's
locked basement locked doors second
floors locked
we've spent much of the day hunting
around for keys Alton found the key to
the second floor in the wine storage of
all places he then immediately lost it
of course I found it on the floor right
outside the guest room where we've made
our base camp for now apparently the
hole in his pockets have gotten big
enough to lose massive 18th century keys
I keep telling him to get some goddamn
new clothes that cheap bastard if we
lose any more keys all blaming him we'll
keep our collection in the guest bedroom
here on the first floor okay so I can't
go in this darkness am I gonna die no
apparently not
I am fine whose go yo huh it is dark
though I'm behind here Hamar I'm behind
here say that might be Oh whines oh no
no is that all a lie how about behind
here no I know hello anybody wall looks
weak ha boom Wow ok I still wait hang on
let me go back I don't know where to
find out lantern doesn't seem to want to
give me one I mean I looked around let's
see in here here nope
I said something about the base camp
being nearby but I don't know what the
dealio is it's awfully dark I'll go
around through this suspicious-looking
hole in the wall wonder who made this oh
hello okey dokey key cellar key and
we're still suck in the first floor
guest room it's not because we've raced
everything up the Roman gets door and
said we don't know what's going on this
is stupid
we're too afraid to just walk out was
just I keep telling myself it was just a
wind howling something mad out there
right now but that wasn't what it
sounded like we're all looking for Frank
when ELISA ran up to us completely
hysterical she was screaming that she
saw something out there we brought her
in the guest bedroom
tried to get her calm down we asked if
it was Frank but she kept saying she
didn't know being Altan thought she was
overreacting you're trying to get her
talk talk her down with something
slammed into the door something big and
heavy
we've been dead silence it had to have
been just the wind
I think our imaginations are making that
sound out to be more than it was but
after what we saw in the cellar I don't
know I don't know what to believe
anymore one of the walls have just about
crumbled and I think I see our workshop
on the other side we're gonna try and
dig our way through I didn't take me
much to dig through maybe I'm a monster
super strong monster they just smashed
right through it okay I don't know where
the frickin lantern oh hello secret
tinderbox it must be back I must back
train you know I must be able to find it
out if I backtrack a bit but I just
don't know it's dark it's dirty dark
hello hello darkness I cast magic I'm
going backwards I don't like that
darkness gives me the heebie-jeebies
it's a bit too dark for my taste
smash any key over here no no aah smash
nope uh-uh anything over here no okay so
there's got to be something over here
like a key that's available hello secret
cinder box
not so secret now Arya Arya hello look
down and um gotta be something that I'm
missing just gotta be oh hello
maybe it's this another note lots of
notes it never matters how well prepared
you come to a job like this packed extra
batteries for the flashlight and what do
you know they're rechargeable kind and
all lack of charge
I will admit this was all my fault of
course Alton tries to cheer me up saying
he brought the charger and asked without
the slightest hint of irony where you
can find a socket Frank the guy who I
don't think even has some high school
degree thought to bring some tinder
boxes and keep some kerosene lanterns
electricity is still unreliable in this
area of Europe so in his town they still
use a candle light in case all manages
to lose something as large as a lantern
we'll keep one in the storage room next
to the library it's surprisingly clean
and organized in there so our stuff
should be easy to find
have to hand it to the previous owners
to keep things nice and tidy for us whoa
I feel like the majority of this his
first part here has been Mihrimah not
that you all mind the sultry sounds of
my voice hey hey am I am I correct
Lantern ah damn it hello all this room
definitely is a nice and tidy s4 damn
shirt don't know where the pile of
bricks came from hello here we go
kliklak at least the tender boxes are
worth something in this can't see ah oil
well that would be useful if I had a
lantern tanda box finding every little
secret besides whatever I need to fly oh
yeah I'm okay like I didn't even use
that all right
damn it seriously where the Fricke flack
is a damned of the dam didn't damn
indeed it did
maybe I could just hammer my way through
whammy no whammy no damn it
where's the damn double key where's the
damn double lantern said storage by the
library that was the library dark eyes
are so dark
aha how about this whammy oh no no not
it oh I'm sorry whammy nope no okay am I
gonna come on I can't be forced to play
this whole game with just just the
Chuck's tinderbox nope nah ah I need a
crowbar obviously for that nothing here
I swear I've been through I've looked
through this the key is obviously not in
this place but it's nearby where nearby
I'm not exactly sure
or at liberty to say dammit alright
and I mean damn it David they've really
hit it maybe it's in here here or here
there's a tinder box I found just about
every secret hit tinderbox every single
secret tinderbox it could possibly be
anywhere to no avail
I know the lanterns in that desk drawer
pun is just it's just not happening
hmmm alright moving on anyway
madam maybe maybe I should look at it
like you know hard mode I'm uh I'm
playing the game with only tinderboxes
you know that's that's fun right that's
uh that should be uh that what the hell
was that what the hell is that
what the hell is that
that is nothing I've ever heard in handy
huh uh huh what the hell was that okay
seriously that made that doubt was
ridiculous nobody slept well chalk it up
to noise planks creak walking wake the
dead Melissa came knocking one two in
the morning spook Melissa she got pissed
on the Frank heard noises some groaning
was going on ah start talking in place
must be haunted
sounds more sheer solitude from one
little noise I don't know what the hell
ha
doors lock you can't be far this is a
cellar key what the hell was that noise
it's really freaking dark
I want a lantern okay it's like I'm
freaking out man I'm freaking out man
you are freaking out man doors locked
he can't be far as this cellar door damn
it I mean I got to find like 10 billion
keys but I found all the tinderbox
second I'm actually out of time
good god no I don't know what's going on
with me I'm freaking out anyways thank
for so much for watching this good
Fianna take some more videos I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye